les amis s'il vous plaît nous allons
commencer
c'est la rentrée des classes aujourd'hui
s'il vous plaît
bon on va commencer
ça va
il y a des mouvements subis
mes chers collègues nous débutons notre
travaux de séjour par une audition
commune des sociétés savantes au sujet
de la fin de vie j'indique cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
du Sénat et qui sera ensuite disponible
en vidéo à la demande cette audition
s'inscrit dans le cadre des travaux que
nous menons sur la question de la fin de
vie travaux mené par leur rapporteur
Christine bonfantier Dossin Corinne
Imbert et Michel meunier ou en plénière
comme ce fut le cas avant la suspension
des travaux parlementaires avec une
table ronde sur des enjeux
philosophiques puis une autre table
ronde sur les enjeux juridiques de ce
sujet nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
docteur manuel de la rivière qui
représentera la société française
d'accompagnement palliatifs le
professeur Jacques-Olivier Bay
représentant la société française du
cancer docteur Sophie Moulias qui
représentera la société française de
gériatrie et de géontologie enfin le
professeur Jérôme Honorat président de
la Société française de neurologie
je vous remercie bien évidemment d'avoir
accepté de participer à ces tables rond
de ce matin et je vais je vous propose
de commencer par un propos liminaire de
chacun relativement bref afin de laisser
la place aux échanges qui suivront
d'abord à partir des questions des
commissaires
que compléteront les rapporteurs bien
évidemment si elles le souhaitent les
rapporteurs font beaucoup d'auditions en
parallèle des auditions plénières et
nous avons eu un déplacement
en Belgique un autre est prévu en Suisse
et les rapporteurs sont également allés
vous êtes allés à la Pitié-Salpêtrière
c'est ça
donc sujet que nous traitons plus
longtemps parce qu'il y avait déjà eu
des propositions de loi présentées au
Sénat et nous avions fait à l'issue une
mission sur l'état des lieux un peu des
soins palliatifs mais vu la tournure
actuelle des événements les annonces du
président de la République et de la
ministre
Agnès Firmin le Bodo nous avons prolongé
cette mission alors je vous laisse la
parole qui commence
du coup je me présente je suis Emmanuel
de la rivière donc je suis médecin de
sois paliative dans une petite
institution
bordelaise ou un petit par sa taille
mais qui est importante sur le plan des
soins palliatifs à Bordeaux et en
Gironde
établissement dans lequel se trouve un
service de soins de suite avec des lits
d'identifier de son palliatifs destinées
à accueillir les patients atteintes de
tumeurs cérébrales
et moi je suis responsable du pôle de
soins palliatifs qui est divisé en trois
avec une unité de soins palliatifs de 12
lits
une équipe mobile de soins palliatifs
qui est à la fois intra-hospitalière
mais également extra-hospitalière qui
intervient à domicile et en
établissement médico-social
essentiellement en EHPAD et puis une
spécificité aussi
à Bordeaux et en Gironde un hôpital de
jour de soins palliatifs qui est quelque
chose qui devrait normalement être amené
à se développer dans l'avenir
hôpital de jour qui a mission
d'accueillir des patients dit
ambulatoire
qui sont à domicile pour une évaluation
pluridisciplinaire autour de ces
questions de la fin de vie et de soins
palliatifs voilà aujourd'hui je
représente donc la société française
d'accompagnement et de soins palliatifs
qui est une société savante qui existe
depuis les années 90 maintenant qui est
une société assez ancienne
et qui se donne pour mission donc de
à la fois de défendre une certaine idée
du soin et de l'accompagnement société
savante qui s'est construite
autour de trois refus le refus
d'abandonner le malade à une époque où
c'était compliqué d'accompagner les
patients en fin de vie
refus de l'obstination des raisonnables
qui reste une question et une réalité
importante encore aujourd'hui mais on
aura peut-être l'occasion d'en parler et
puis refus
de donner délibérément la mort de faire
de pratiquer je dirais au sens large
injection létale quelle que soit ces
modalités euthanasies ou ou suicide
assisté
voilà ce que je pourrais vous dire en
présentation
professeur B
mesdames mesdames me laisser notre
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
Présidente merci
déjà de d'avoir invité donc la société
française du cancer de venir essayer de
témoigner un petit peu ou de vous parler
un petit peu de de ce qu'est la fin de
vie au regard de cette maladie qui est
finalement une maladie malheureusement
très fréquente et avec une chronicité
qui fait que effectivement le nombre de
malades augmente en incidence ne
serait-ce qu'à cause de cette chronicité
et la fin de vie est effectivement un
sujet important pour nous puisque
beaucoup malheureusement de pathologies
cancéreuses ne sont pas guérissables et
que reste à définir cette fin de vie
parfois j'oserais dire dans sa longueur
parce que on a des malades qui peuvent
vivre finalement très très longtemps
alors en ce qui me concerne moi je suis
effectivement
professeur des universités en oncologie
médicale avec une activité à la fois en
hématologie et plus spécifiquement donc
en non-co-immatologie mais également en
oncologie médicale ou j'ai donc la
direction de ces deux services au CHU de
Clermont-Ferrand je représente ici la
société française du cancer et j'ai
également l'honneur de présider l'agence
de biométrie pour lequel on a aussi
beaucoup de travailler comme vous le
savez au regard de la loi de bioéthique
et qui finalement recoupe parfois
certaines préoccupations qu'on peut
avoir dans la prise en charge de nos
patients merci
bonjour à toutes et à tous madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup en tout cas de
d'avoir aussi convié la société
française de gériatrie donc moi je suis
le docteur Sophie Moulia je suis médecin
gériat je suis aussi docteur en éthique
et donc je travaille à l'hôpital
l'Ambroise paré à l'estance publique
hôpitaux de Paris ou j'ai monté il y a
fort longtemps maintenant une unité de
gériatrie aigu en 2004 donc ça fait
bientôt 19 ans et
actuellement je développe l'équipe
mobile ce qu'on appelle l'équipe mobile
gériatrique externe c'est-à-dire que je
vais faire essentiellement
du soin dans les EHPAD et en ville pour
essayer de développer la culture
gériatrique et aussi la culture
palliative dans les à l'extérieur de
l'hôpital
alors en gériatrie on a on a une
spécialité assez mal connue parce que
généralement les gens boudent un peu
quand ils y arrivent ils ont pas
forcément envie de voir un gériatre on a
une spéci en fait qui qui a une approche
médico-psée psychosociale ce qui est un
petit peu
particulier et à ce titre là on a
développé de fait une réflexion éthique
de longue date aussi pour la
l'approche la qualité et la quantité des
soins que toute société aujourd'hui
développe mais qu'on a qu'on a développé
longtemps on a une population un peu
particulière puisqu'elle est
souvent limitée à la population d'epad
alors que l'immense majorité des
personnes âgées vivent à domicile et non
en EHPAD mais que le raccourci en
particulier le raccourci sociétal veut
qu'on quand on parle du rentage on ne
voit que les personnes extrêmement
dépendantes que les personnes
qui vivent en EHPAD qui ne représentent
moins de 5% de la population que nous
avons à
prendre en considération nous avons
comme tant d'autres un gros problème
d'accès aux soins que ça soit en ville
ou à l'hôpital ou clairement la
culture gériatrique et la l'accès aux
soins gériatriques n'est pas née
actuellement pas développé et nous avons
à en fait des batailles de longues dates
la première et l'agisme
qui est en fait la discrimination sur
l'âge qui est aujourd'hui
flambant en fait qui a toujours existé
mais qui est totalement comment dire ça
décomplexifié en fait depuis le covid où
tout le monde a le droit de dire ce
qu'il veut et qui fait partie de nos
inquiétudes particulières nous sommes
une spécialité d'accompagnement puisque
la mort fait partie de notre métier
aussi bien que la vie mais pour vivre en
fait il faut accepter de vieillir et
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui peut-être un
succès pour notre société c'est à dire
notre longévité hors norme par rapport à
la majorité des pays du globe semblaient
être aujourd'hui une problématique dont
souffre beaucoup
la population et les enfin la population
âgée et notre spécialité et donc nous
avons aussi toute une tranche de métiers
à développer en développement qui sont
beaucoup pointés du doigt très très mal
connu qui sont les métiers du grand âge
en général pas que les métiers médicaux
pas que les métiers soignants et il y a
encore des métiers à inventer et quand
je parle de métier ça veut dire de
reconnaissance ça veut dire de savoir
aussi de formation et de respect des uns
et des autres on parle beaucoup du
respect du patient ce qui est normal il
faut aussi parler du respect du
professionnel et pour être professionnel
il faut être un vrai professionnel
puis libre à vous de vous saisir ou pas
de ces questions là mais en tout cas
nous c'est des vrais préoccupations pour
nous
merci beaucoup messieurs mesdames les
sénateurs et les membres de la
commission donc je suis le professeur
Honorat je suis neuroncologue à Lyon
donc je m'occupe de la prise en charge
des des tumeurs cérébrales qui sont des
cancers et les patients cumulent à la
fois la prise en charge du cancer et le
handicap neurologique qui survient assez
rapidement et qui est variable en
fonction de la localisation de La de la
tumeur
c'est une pathologie pour lequel la mort
malheureusement est un élément
extrêmement prévenant la tumeur la plus
fréquente c'est le glioblastome pour
lequel il y a pas de traitement curatif
c'est à peu près 3000 patients en France
et la médiane de survie est actuellement
autour de 16 mois donc dans mon service
il y a toujours en permanence
2 7 patients qui sont en soit palliatifs
dans le service d'hospitalisation qui
prend également en charge tous les
patients pour lequel on fait le
diagnostic ou qui s'aggravent au cours
de leur de leur maladie je représente
aujourd'hui la Société française de
neurologie pour lesquelles
la prise en charge des patients en fin
de vie est extrêmement important dans
différentes pathologies avec différentes
natures de prise en charge
vous avez naturellement les démences qui
sont un élément important mais qui ont
une évolution extrêmement lente sur
plusieurs années
la Sclérose Latérale a myotrophique où
les patients vont décéder avec une
médiane de 2 à 3 ans et
en pleine conscience bien que c'est un
élément qu'il faudrait rediscuter
qu'est-ce que c'est que la conscience
est la vraie capacité de
d'appréhender de raisonner ce qui se
passe les accidents vasculaires
cérébraux ou les
accidents de la de la vie qui peuvent
conduire des
des handicaps extrêmement sévères et
puis les tumeurs cérébrales qui sont un
élément important
je voudrais insister sur la façon dont
les les neurologues appréhendent la la
conscience
les phénomènes biologiques qui
conduisent à cette capacité
d'appréhender le vivant l'extérieur les
échanges qui se modifient en fonction de
circonstances extérieur et propre à la
personne et pour lequel à un moment
donné on peut penser d'une manière et
puis finalement on va évoluer d'une
façon différente si on prend l'exemple
de mon activité personnelle sur les
glioblastomes qui
prie comme je viens de vous l'expliquer
on se dit c'est tellement terrible que
comment affronter une pathologie comme
celle-là
en fait dans ma carrière en 30 ans je
crois que
j'ai dû observer une fois et c'était
même pas un Guillaume blastome un
patient qui a réellement demandé à en
finir et qui ne voulait pas aller plus
loin chacun chemine et avance dans sa
façon d'appréhender les choses au fur et
à mesure de l'évolution de la maladie et
il n'est jamais temps et le handicap n'a
jamais suffisant pour pouvoir penser
qu'il faut en finir et qu'il faut
s'arrêter donc ça je pense que c'est un
élément extrêmement important dans les
dans les discussions
je voudrais aussi souligner
le manque de moyens et d'enseignement
dont dispose actuellement les médecins
pour appréhender la fin de vie et la
prise en charge de la fin de vie il y a
des services de soins palliatifs on a
des structures mais cette hétérogène sur
le territoire
et un exemple tout simple dans mon
service je vous ai dit 2 à 700
palliatifs en permanence le personnel
supplémentaire alloué à cette activité
c'est 0,8 équivalent en plein qui ne
correspond à rien puisque en permanence
on a 1,2 équivalent en plein qui est en
arrêt de travail pour différentes
raisons et qui ne travaillent pas donc
en fait les
personnels supplémentaires la
structuration pour accueillir ces
patients c'est zéro c'est les mêmes
personnes qui font à la fois le
diagnostic le soin le suivi et les soins
palliatifs avec extrêmement peu de
personnel et de moyens
voilà je suis ouvert pour les toutes les
questions et
merci
qui a des questions
important moi auparavant j'avais une
question vous qui vivez au quotidien
c'est c'est fin de vie finalement par
des pathologies
les pathologies que vous avez décrites
ou par l'âge le grand âge même si en
effet vieillissement n'est pas forcément
dépendante mais est-ce que vous sentez
le besoin de légiférer de nouveau parce
qu'à la législation actuelle n'est pas
suffisante on parle beaucoup j'entendais
la ministrière nous dire certes la loi
Leonetti bon après il y a l'application
la connaissance les soins palliatifs les
unités qui permettent de faire cette
citation profonde et continue jusqu'au
dessin mais il reste des cas comme la
maladie de Charcot
est-ce que est-ce que vous sentez un
besoin est-ce que vous êtes en phase
avec les conclusions de la je sais plus
comment la Convention citoyenne c'est ça
est-ce que vous êtes en phase avec ces
conclusions ou est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on passe qu'on bascule pas c'est une
opinion personnelle qu'on ne bascule pas
finalement d'une parce que souvent on
dit on va aménager la loi de non on
bascule sur autre chose que le suicide
assisté ou encore plus l'euthanasie à
mes yeux c'est un choix de société
Antoine d'accéder à des demandes de
une forme de droit à mourir à choisir sa
mort est-ce que vous vous sentez ce
besoin d'une nouvelle loi est-ce que
vous êtes bloqué par par la législation
actuelle qui serait trop restrictive
qui veut commencer
pour ce qui concerne la neurologie
on est actuellement en ayant interrogé
l'ensemble de mes camarades de peu gêner
et on a l'arsenal nécessaire en fait la
pathologie dans lequel on recourt à la
sédation c'est la sclérose latérale
amyotrophique mais j'ai des patients
pour lequel on est dans une évolution de
la maladie importante qui sont
insuffisants respiratoires et pour
lequel la sédation va conduire à un
arrêt
de la vie un peu plus précoce que il ne
serait survenu si on avait laissé les
choses évoluer et parfois dans des
conditions beaucoup plus apaisée et
préparer donc on a l'arsenal pour
pouvoir prendre en charge dans les
autres pathologies
rentrent en ligne de compte les
capacités du patient a décidé et à dire
à quel moment on est susceptible de
faire je pense que la fin de vie telle
qu'on est susceptible de le vivre avec
nos patients
est un élément extrêmement important de
la vie et des patients nous rapportent
que les
derniers mois quatre derniers mois
qu'ils ont vécu avec leur maladie leur
semble beaucoup plus importantes
condensé forte que ce qu'ils ont pu
vivre auparavant
sans qu'il y ait de demande explicite de
dire ben non faut que ça s'arrête par
contre c'est extrêmement tendu et
difficile ça c'est certain et ça
nécessite des échanges extrêmement
importants
quand il n'y a plus de contact du tout
c'est également difficile mais je suis
assez
dubitatif sur la façon dont il faut
traiter le problème parce qu'il faut que
ça évite et ce qui va se passer ensuite
avec le deuil de chaque personne c'est à
dire le processus de deuil à partir du
moment où vous perdez quelqu'un c'est
aussi réfléchir qu'est-ce qui se passe
ou est-ce qu'il va qu'est-ce que quel
est le mécanisme de fin de vie est-ce
que c'est bien ou c'est pas bien quand
c'est extrêmement tendu difficile il
arrive un moment où on finit par se dire
c'est mieux qu'il parte et à partir du
moment on a commencé à faire cette
démarche c'est mieux qu'il parte on a
commencé son processus de deuil et à ce
moment là
dans les mois les semaines à venir on
sera plus apaisé et mieux
si brutalement on fait quelque chose ça
peut être très bien dans les heures qui
suivent dans les semaines qui suivent et
puis à un moment donné on est
susceptible de se poser la question mais
est-ce que j'ai bien fait et est-ce
qu'on aurait pas pu quand même faire un
tout petit peu plus c'est dans des
conditions qui étaient tout à fait
[Musique]
admissible et paisible donc je pense que
le la problématique n'est pas simple du
tout et que on voit malheureusement avec
les modes de vie la façon d'appréhender
la mort actuellement elle est cachée
elle se fait à l'hôpital dans des
conditions qui sont souvent en dehors de
la vie normale
et on oublie que c'est une évolution
naturelle de la vie et que c'est
extrêmement important ici on le vit pas
complètement au culte et à un moment
donné c'est susceptible de resurgir dans
des difficultés psychologiques
extrêmement importantes
au comptage
cette impression que on met le grand
grand âge dans des
un peu ce que nous a dit philosophes
et favorable aussi pour le grand grand
âge le grand grand handicap et
un cancer en face terminale mais je veux
dire le grand grand âge ça fait partie
de la vie aussi
des personnes qui a obtenu les propos
les plus agistes pendant le pendant le
covid ce qui est toujours une posture
intéressante quand on a son âge mais
ça c'est dit
mais
sans doute sans forcément peut-être voir
la posture qui avait derrière
le grand âge ça fait partie de la vie et
c'est pas une maladie d'avoir un grand
âge même si même un âge très avancé on
meurt toujours de maladies les
centenaires ont plusieurs maladies
chroniques en eux convaincu tranquille
avec eux et puis un jour il y en a une
qui dit que c'est le moment de partir et
on meurt on peut mourir dans son lit
tranquillement de maladie sans soins
palliatifs et sans et sans douleur
abominable
il reste que
en fait voilà il y a la confrontation
d'une posture philosophique avec une
posture alors je sais pas pratique
peut-être ou une posture de vie qui est
un petit peu compliqué et c'est pour ça
que au niveau de la société française de
gériatrie et gérontologie on est très
inquiet parce que
comme je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
en fait la vision qu'on a du grand âge
est une vision assez négative et du coup
on l'a bien vu pendant le covid on a
volontiers une posture dominante au nom
de la vulnérabilité en imposant aux
autres ce qui nous semble le mieux pour
eux et à partir du moment où on a mis
alors ça veut rien dire personne âgée on
est tous âgé de notre âge et on est tous
le vieux d'un autre et le jeune d'un
autre voilà je donc c'est un peu
compliqué quand on commence à utiliser
un terme chronologique pour définir
quelque chose à la limite déjà quand on
parle de dépendance dans le grand âge on
parle de handicap chez les plus jeunes
donc si on parle de handicap chez tout
le monde c'est peut-être plus simple si
on parle de ce type de posture ça permet
un peu de simplifier le propos mais
aujourd'hui comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure on résume le grand âge le plus
part du temps à la démence et à l'Ehpad
avec des stades très avancés de
dépendance
ou en fait les personnes ne demandent
pas à mourir on EHPAD après les
personnes qui ont
des souffrances intenses elles demandent
à être accompagnée elle demande à être
soignée elle demande à être soulagée
qu'elle le demande expressément par
leurs paroles ou par leur corps ça c'est
une nécessité ou aujourd'hui encore en
France on n'arrive pas à faire face
partout ça c'est vrai mais c'est pas
pour autant que les personnes demandent
à mourir et on voit bien que dans les
deux postures qui se mettent côte à côte
il y a
la loi clécelonetti c'est une loi pour
qui a été faite pour accompagner ceux
qui vont mourir
le en tout cas les conclusions de la
de la convention citoyenne c'est une
proposition façon des arguments pour
ceux qui veulent mourir ce qui sont deux
positions différentes en tout cas dans
la vie
du gériatre
[Musique]
et c'est une réalité ou la mort ne nous
semble pas une réponse en tout cas
acceptable aujourd'hui si on met pas
autre chose en place aussi à côté
merci
je pourrais peut-être ajouter
effectivement
tout ce qui peut concerner la pathologie
cancéreuse au sens général du terme mon
confrère a parlé effectivement de
maladies terriblement dramatique avec
des atteintes neurologiques qui
effectivement peuvent aussi concerner
parfois des maladies purement
neurologiques en tout cas en
cancérologie je crois qu'on a une chance
alors peut-être que le mot je parle pas
par rapport à la maladie en elle-même on
a une chance c'est d'avoir une
organisation finalement par l'Institut
national du cancer et les différents
plans cancers qui ont permis à un moment
ou un autre de prendre conscience et de
nous faire prendre conscience à nous
finalement médecin de ce que pouvait
être les soins de support et dans ces
soins de support bien sûr il faut
compter les soins palliatifs et la prise
en charge finalement palliatifs de nos
patients alors je rejoindrai un petit
peu ce que
ce que ma consera dit c'est quand même
assez rare y compris en cancérologie
d'avoir une vraie demande de fin de vie
je dirais brutal quoi c'est à dire de
suicides assister ou de ou de
d'euthanasie c'est quand même très très
rare et
je ne dis pas que ça n'existe pas et
d'ailleurs ça serait totalement incongru
de dire que ça n'existe pas et c'est
peut-être ce qu'il faut d'ailleurs un
moment ou un autre prendre aussi en
compte mais la question de c'est de
savoir parfois pourquoi des patients en
arrivent à cette à cette extrémité de
souhait et
j'arrive quand même parfois bien souvent
dans ma pratique à penser que la loi
classe néolithique n'est pas toujours
toujours très très bien appliqué et que
aujourd'hui il faudrait déjà qu'on
arrive vraiment nous médecins nous
personnel paramédicaux et puis peut-être
aussi une éducation sociétale à faire en
sorte que cette loi classée monétise
soit finalement appliquée correctement
précocement qu'elle soit discutée
organisée dans la dans la dans la mise
en oeuvre et que ça permettrait à mon
avis de dénouer beaucoup de beaucoup de
ces situations qui sont extrêmement
complexes et à mon avis je pense en tout
cas par rapport à la cancérologie que je
j'insisterai vraiment là-dessus sur sur
l'application du mieux possible de cette
loi plutôt que de privilégier des
raccourcis alors le mot peut paraître
extrêmement excessif mais je trouve
qu'on peut arriver à ces extrémités là
quand on est sûr que tout a été fait
avant et aujourd'hui je ne suis pas sûr
que tout a été fait avant
alors je ne peux que confirmer ce qui a
été dit par ma concert et mes confrères
sur le nombre de demandes de morts
anticipées de mon expérience de 13 ans
maintenant de de travail en médecine
palliative parce que mon métier
précédent c'était la médecine d'urgence
je l'ai pas dit en me présentant mais je
travaille pendant 13 ans dans un service
de médecine d'urgence depuis que je
pratique donc cette médecine dite
palliative le nombre de patients que
j'ai accompagné et qui ont persisté dans
leur demande de mort anticipée ce compte
sur les doigts d'une seule main et je
les identifie bien peut-être ce qui est
nouveau
c'est que j'ai l'impression donc sur les
doigts de cette main que les deux ou
trois derniers étaient dans les deux ou
trois dernières années donc peut-être
que quelque chose s'accélère mais je
pense au titre du fait que
c'est de plus en plus prégnant peut-être
dans
dans les médias dans les représentations
que peuvent avoir les malades maintenant
ça reste effectivement très anecdotique
faut-il modifier la loi pour cela je ne
le pense pas vous évoquez tout à l'heure
cette question de la sclérose latérale
amyotrophile donc de la maladie de
Charcot dont on parle beaucoup dans les
médias et qui feraient que la loi
devrait être modifiée je pense c'est
important et de préciser que parce que
moi je suis beaucoup de patients
atteints de cette maladie alors quand je
dis beaucoup ça représente quand même
pas un nombre très important de malade
mais malgré tout beaucoup sont en fin de
vie et beaucoup vont être accompagnés
par nos services de soins palliatifs je
pense que c'est important de ne pas
stigmatiser ces malades et de faire de
d'une éventuelle nouvelle loi une
maladie une loi destinée aux patients
atteints de cette maladie les retours
que j'ai en fait de des patients qu'on
suit
de cette maladie de Charcot beaucoup
ressentent comme
j'allais dire
par cette stigmatisation du fait de dire
qu'il faudrait faire une loi pour l'ASLA
le fait que il serait peut-être de trop
sur cette terre et qu'il n'aurait pas à
vivre tout ce temps qu'ils ont à vivre
jusqu'à de la fin naturelle de leur vie
donc je voulais je commençais juste par
vous dire ça je trouve ça un peu
inadapté que la ministre comme vous
l'avez dit est repris à nouveau hier ou
avant-hier dans une émission télévisée
cette question de la maladie de Charcot
l'autre chose concernant la loi Claisse
Leonetti je pense que c'est important de
ne pas réduire la loi classes léonétique
à la sédation profonde et continuer
maintenue jusqu'au décès c'est juste une
toute petite partie de la loi et la loi
classe Leonetti s'inscrit dans le
prolongement de la loi Leonetti j'ai été
assez touché par une tribune qui a été
publiée
quelques semaines par Claire Fourcade
donc la présidente de la SFAP qu'elle
attribué qu'elle a publié conjointement
avec un député communiste dans
l'humanité il me semble et qui dit que
la loi enfin qui dit dans son titre que
la loi Léonetti est un trésor national
je pense effectivement
que c'est un trésor national et que
c'est ce trésor nous aide
quotidiennement dans notre pratique
quotidienne du soin il est important à
mon avis de ne pas réduire la loi
Claisse Leonetti uniquement aux
questions de sédation profonde et
continue maintenu jusqu'au décès qui
représente à nouveau pas la majorité des
patients que que l'on accompagne alors
une nouvelle loi
pourquoi je suis assez sensible à ce que
vous avez dit madame la Présidente sur
le fait que
si on instaurait une loi permettant
l'administration d'un produit létal quel
qu'il soit quel que soit sa forme ce
serait pas un prolongement des lois
précédentes mais ce serait pour moi
un changement de direction voilà comme
le disait ma conso nous nous occupons
des patients qui vont mourir
s'il faut faire une nouvelle loi pour
les patients qui veulent mourir alors
que ils ne sont pas forcément en fin de
vie je pense que on changerait
effectivement de paradigme on changerait
de direction et ce ne serait pas un
prolongement des lois précédentes avec
tout l'impact que ça pourrait avoir pour
les professionnels de santé
merci alors Bernard Chaumier Annick
chaque mai Olivier nobernard Chaumier
merci Madame à présidente merci à vous
toutes et tous pour vos propos j'ai deux
questions à vous poser la première
monsieur de la rivière vous avez rappelé
dans votre première intervention que
l'obscination des raisonnable existait
encore aujourd'hui et j'aimerais que
vous nous expliquer
pourquoi
quelles sont ces mécanismes
est-ce que c'est le plus fréquemment
venant de l'entourage de la personne
concernée est-ce que ça peut venir des
soignants et qu'est-ce que ça révèle
dans ce cas là que des pratiques
d'obstation raisonnables soient encore
en cours du côté des soignants c'est ma
première question la deuxième
elle nous amène un peu au coeur du débat
il a incontestable que nos concitoyens
sont majoritairement je ne sais pas dans
quelle proportion exacte mes favorable à
l'ouverture d'un droit à décider de sa
fin de vie
la convention citoyenne a montré
d'ailleurs que quand on entre dans les
modalités
la complexité apparaît et que différents
types de réponses peuvent être apportées
il est tout aussi incontestable que à
peu près là je pense l'ensemble des
sociétés savantes qui travaillent sur
cette question très grande majorité des
professionnels des soins palliatifs eux
ne sont pas favorables
à l'ouverture à ce changement de loi
enfin c'était la question de Catherine
Deroche et à l'ouverture d'un d'un
nouveau droit pour pour nos concitoyens
le CCE a tenté de conjuguer dans son
dernier avis qui est très intéressant
qui a été interprété comme oui on peut
ouvrir l'aide activa mourir au fond il
tente de de concilier ces positions en
disant en y mettant une liste de
conditionnalités qui quand on les
regarde c'est-à-dire en terme
d'effectivité de l'application parce
qu'il suffit pas d'avoir un trésor il
faut qu'il servent à quelque chose sinon
on est content on est assis sur un tador
mais ça profite à personne et
l'effectivité de l'application de la loi
on court après depuis voilà bon on va
pas revenir sur toutes ces débat là tout
le monde les connaît mais le CCNE donc a
mis des conditionnalités qui sont très
strictes en fait à l'ouverture de ce
droit notamment en termes d'égalité
d'accès l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
aux soins palliatifs et à une fin de vie
la plus entourée possible on va dire sur
un plan de l'apaisement
comment vous comment vous proposez
l'avancée parce que je vais être un peu
un peu cash comme d'hab mais en gros
tout ce que vous nous avez dit on le
sait enfin vous on l'a entendu de toutes
vos sociétés savantes depuis bien
longtemps mais ça ça veut dire on ne
touche pas effectivement à la loi on ne
donne pas suite à la demande qui est
encore une fois celle de nos concitoyens
moi je voudrais qu'on cherche la voix
parce que je pense qu'elle existe et je
voudrais que vous vous nous disiez vous
disiez par exemple parce que j'entends
très bien quand vous dites au fond ça
concerne vous avez dit moi c'était cinq
personnes il y a trois ans vous avez dit
c'est très peu de personnes qui seraient
concernées oui peut-être mais donc
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour faire en
sorte que à la fois les soins palliatifs
soient réellement une réalité dans notre
pays et que dans un certain nombre de
situations peut-être très limitée en
terme numérique
ce droit à une aide active à mourir puis
cette ouvert à nos concitoyens est-ce
que pour vous c'est antinomique ou
est-ce qu'il y a une voix comme le CCNE
semble indiquer
va prendre plusieurs commissaires Annick
Jacques mais
merci président de mes propos vont
rejoindre un petit peu
ceux de mon collègue
professeur Honorat oui vous avez dit un
seul patient en 30 ans finalement vous a
demandé
cette aide à mourir est-ce que vous
pensez que
la difficulté vient plus de la famille
qui regarde qui insiste qui a peut-être
du mal à comprendre et que c'est plus
enfin je veux pas dire c'est plus elle
qui souffre que le malade mais est-ce
que c'est plus elle qui a du mal à
accepter finalement ce départ qui
s'approche et qui se dit bah voilà
est-ce qu'on va les aider à passer ce
cap ou pas donc est-ce que est-ce que
dans les soins palliatifs il y a aussi
cet accompagnement de la famille est-ce
que il est pris suffisamment en amont ou
pas
et bon on a tous vécu des choses
difficiles dans nos familles et c'est
parfois un peu difficile de faire la
part des choses quand on est législateur
et qu'on doit prendre une décision pour
les autres parce que forcément on est
impacté parce qu'on a vu et vécu et
professeur B vous disiez aussi que cette
cette fin de vie s'est accompagnement
enfin moi j'ai vécu dans ma famille un
manque de ma famille qui a demandé à
mourir et qui a demandé justement cet
assistance à mourir en Suisse alors
oui est-ce que pour le petit nombre qui
va le demander et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
parce que je suis d'accord il y a déjà
des lois qui existent mais quand on est
face à cette demande quand on est face à
ce désarroi enfin on peut pas rester
sans rien faire et on est on est tout nu
on est tout bête on est tout enfin on
sait pas comment faire alors oui voilà
on se pose quand même un peu je pense
tous ces questions là et la conférence
citoyenne de fin de vie qui va se finir
on voit bien que ça évolue dans la
société alors faut bien aussi qu'on
amène une réponse on sait d'autre part
qui m'ont terriblement de médecins ou
d'unité de soins palliatifs alors
comment est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
pourrait les développer plus c'est
sûrement une question d'argent mais
peut-être pas que alors voilà on a plein
de questions on voudrait avoir des
réponses merci
Oliviero on va prendre toutes les
questions merci madame la Présidente
merci pour vos propos je crois qu'il y a
une quête éternelle de de l'humanité de
de prolonger la vie et il me semble que
du point de vue de l'opinion des
opinions occidentales au moins se pose
la question maintenant du sens c'est ça
au fond du sens de projet et de
prolonger la vie
en état de d'une forme de dépendance
et ça c'est bouleversant en quelque
sorte mais je crois que c'est ça qui est
inscrit dans la convention citoyenne et
donc que pensez-vous ça a basculement
alors par rapport à ce que le mot on
peut on peut résister on peut écouter
enfin il y a plusieurs attitudes tout au
nord d'ailleurs
possible mais est-ce que au-delà de la
législation vous voyez des des personnes
qui s'interrogent sur ça
est-ce que il peut même y avoir sans
légiférer des suicides pas forcément
besoin de de d'une aide quelquefois pour
partir est-ce que tout ça commence à
émerger c'est ma première question enfin
comment voyez-vous tout ça parce que
c'est une réalité dans dans l'opinion à
cette peur de la de la dépendance et
puis la la deuxième question est-ce que
vous avez des échanges avec les sociétés
savantes dans les pays qui ont légiféré
sur l'aide à mourir terrible terme je
pense à la Suisse je pense à la Belgique
ou ça fait quand même plusieurs dizaines
d'années de 2002 je pense
et comment ça se passe dans ces pays
est-ce qu'il y a des échanges avec les
sociétés savantes et et quelle est la
nature de ces échanges s'il y en a je
vous remercie
terminer alors Daniel Chassin
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames Mesdames et Messieurs les
professeurs pour vos propos donc ce que
vous avez indiqué
beaucoup de médecins leur rencontre dans
leur carrière
et en fait on trouve beaucoup de gens
qui disent lorsqu'ils sont en très bonne
santé moi je veux pas être comme ça je
vais mourir mais en fait lorsque les
personnes
sont dépendantes ou ont des
ont des maladies que vous avez décrit
extrêmement grave on en trouve
extrêmement peu qui disent on veut
mourir par euthanasie ou suicide
assister mais elle demande
un accompagnement effectivement et au
bout de d'un certain temps quand on
arrive
vraiment à la fin avec des troubles de
l'alimentation des douleurs on peut
aller progressivement accompagner avec
la sédation profonde et continue et donc
je pense que la loi Léonetti est classée
une excellente loi et dans certains pays
notamment les Pays-Bas certains
indiquent que s'il y avait eu des soins
palliatifs et bien ils ne saurait pas il
n'aurait pas créé de de
loi sur le suicide assisté où le tanasie
la convention citoyenne a du reste en
France surtout
fait connaître les soins palliatifs
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens en fait
qui ignoraient que dans leur département
il y avait des soins palliatifs
donc voilà ma question simplement ne
faudrait-il pas simplement augmenter le
personnel dans les services de soins
palliatifs dans tous les départements
puisque il n'y a pas de service de soins
palliatifs spécifiques dans tous les
départements et aussi renforcer le
service de soins palliatifs mobile qui
rendent des services de façon très très
importante pour les médecins
généralistes et les paramédicaux à
domicile et en EHPAD merci bon je vous
laisse répondre parce qu'on a aussi
d'autres questions alors qui commence à
répondre monsieur
buffet merci madame la Présidente
plusieurs questions et des questions
pour lesquelles effectivement c'est pas
forcément trop facile de trouver les
bonnes réponses mais je voudrais juste
essayer de
vous alerter si toutefois c'est possible
sur vraiment quelques points qui me
paraissent clé
le premier c'est que tous nos patients
mais nous-mêmes on change dans nos vies
et on change en fonction des événements
qui peuvent
survenir et notamment des problèmes de
santé et on peut très bien avoir une
opinion à un moment donné et en avoir
une autre un autre moment au regard
justement d'une maladie et on a
énormément de nos patients qui vont nous
dire par exemple en fin de consultation
je revois dans un an si je suis toujours
là et dépendamment de comment je serai
et ils sont toujours là et ils sont
toujours contents d'être là et parfois
il faut vraiment qu'on ait en pleine
conscience
que les changements de nos opinions sont
vraiment j'oser constant le deuxième
point qui me paraît important c'est que
on a aussi des jugements et madame la
sénatrice vous l'avez rappelé par vos
expériences personnelles on a on est
forcément influencé nous-mêmes nous
médecins par nos expériences
personnelles qui peuvent être familiales
mais qui peuvent être aussi sur des
exemples très particuliers je suis
convaincu qu'à la fin de ma carrière je
garderai en mémoire quelques situations
vraiment clés qu'auront vraiment marqué
finalement ma profession et
malheureusement ces éléments clés
parfois nous peuvent nous distorsionner
dans nos dans nos mécanismes de
raisonnement
et ma troisième réflexion c'est que je
ne suis pas sûr en tout cas moi au titre
de la société française du cancer que il
y ait une opposition à une prise en
compte de situation dramatiques
extrêmement complexe difficile et pour
laquelle une fin de vie que ce soit par
suicide assisté ou que ce soit par
l'euthanasie puisse être requise
demandée et que ce soit encadré par une
loi le propos par contre c'est que avant
d'en arriver là encore une fois il faut
être sûr que tout ait pu être réalisé
avant et c'est vrai que on assiste nous
bien souvent dans nos professions le
sentiment de d'incapacité de pouvoir
faire parfaitement ce que nous devrions
faire notamment en termes de soins de
support et plus particulièrement en
termes de soins palliatifs
d'accompagnement et de ce fait
je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait vraiment une
réticence il y a simplement la volonté
d'être sûr qu'avant tout est pu être
vraiment mis en œuvre pour que la
décision qui puisse enfin en tout cas ce
que souhaiterait vraiment nos patients
soient totalement éclairés au regard de
ces changements de personnalité au fil
de la vie de prendre en compte
effectivement le personnel médical et
paramédical mais aussi d'être vraiment
sûr que tout a été fait avant
merci alors pour essayer de répondre
dans l'ordre en ce qui concerne
l'obtination des raisonnables il y a
plusieurs choses la première c'est les
citoyens ne connaissent pas les soins
palliatifs ils ne savent pas ce qui est
possible de faire ou de ne pas faire ils
ne connaissent pas les dispositifs
légaux de personnes de confiance la
possibilité de faire des directives
anticipées très compliquées d'écrire ces
directives anticipées c'est très
compliqué d'anticiper sa propre mort et
ses situations de défaillance si
soi-même on est pas malade et qu'on n'a
pas déjà expérimenté des choses qui nous
ont paru trop ou qui nous ont pas eu
déjà très difficiles et en tout cas en
gériatrie les familles elles demandent
la vie clairement les familles à chaque
fois qu'on leur dit bah là le processus
terminal est en place la majorité
d'entre elles nous disent c'est pas
possible vous avez pas tout essayé vous
êtes bien sûr on pourrait pas aller
surtout depuis le covid où on a opposé
enfin on a travaillé sur un faux
paradigme médiatisé qui est quand on va
une animation c'est qu'on vit quand on
va pas en réanimation c'est qu'on meurt
absolument alors qu'en tout cas dans le
grand âge ce paradigme est faux
clairement on vit mieux quand on va pas
en réanimation il y a des tonnes
d'études qui vous montrent ça pour plein
plein de raisons après il y a il y a
plein de choses les soignants c'est bien
d'écrire une loi ça c'est plus votre
métier que le nôtre mais par contre il
faut encore donner les possibilités de
son application et que clairement la loi
te laisse leonétique est en effet une
loi formidable à vivre au quotidien et
essentiellement la loi Leonetti en fait
qui nous a permis de faire rentrer
quelqu'un pour les discussions de
limitation de soins de savoir jusqu'où
on va etc qui a permis le refus de soins
et donc de poser la question du de
l'obstination des raisonnable
à un niveau officiel on va dire pour nos
pratiques
par contre
leur connaissance de ces lois là comment
est-ce qu'on fait en pratique pour dire
que là il y a une obstination
déraisonnable quelle autre soit on peut
proposer est-ce qu'il y a des
professionnels qui savent
qu'on peut proposer quels soins de
confort de support quel autre soit on
peut proposer ça c'est pas uniforme sur
le territoire donc ça c'est en tout cas
ce qui manque aujourd'hui et qui a un
constat je pense de toutes nos sociétés
qui est que l'inquiétude qu'on perçoit
actuellement chez nos citoyens c'est
qu'est-ce qui a d'autres que on va dire
le soin curatif or il y a d'autres
possibilités aucun d'entre nous
n'abandonne ses patients mais par contre
les citoyens ne savent pas ça en tout
cas on le ressent nous chez nos patients
et chez leurs proches et donc il faut
aussi s'interroger à ce niveau là la
question du suicide aujourd'hui le
suicide n'est plus interdit en France
par contre il est toujours moralement
très peiné très pénalisé nous en tant
que professionnel quand un patient
arrive suicidé on a l'obligation de le
réanimer c'est une obligation
morale et écrite dans les lois de la
société de réanimation on doit réanimer
un suicidé
ce qui pose la question de si on
autorise le suicide assisté et qu'est-ce
qu'on va voilà s'il y a un suicidé qu'on
a droit de pas réanimer qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des autres en tout cas enfin
j'imagine que vous écoutez aussi la
société de réanimation mais ça fait
partie de des vrais problématiques le
suicide existe aussi dans le grand âge
donc on peut en parler et quand pour ce
qui concerne le sens de prolonger la vie
dans un état de dépendance ça pose
plusieurs questions la première c'est la
question de la valeur de la vie et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui en tout cas la
valeur de la vie existe du alors du jour
de la naissance
on n'est pas encore la question de la
prénessence voilà mais en tout cas du
jour de la naissance jusqu'au jour de sa
mort
à ma connaissance aujourd'hui en France
la valeur de la vie est la même
reste à savoir que si on pose la
question que peut-être que dans la
grande dépendance la valeur de la vie
serait moins à considérer que quand on
n'est pas dépendant ou quand voilà quel
ça pose d'autres questions qui en tout
cas qu'on ressent bien dans le aussi
dans les services avec les personnes
possibles relationnelles on voit des
gens qui des familles des proches qui
nous disent ben ça en tout cas qui
projette leur propre souffrance sur
l'état du sujet on n'a pas de réponse
forcément pour répondre à ça tout ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que ces personnes
là elles ont aussi des signes de
vitalité
et qui ne sont
malgré leur grande dépendance
et qu'en tout cas philosophiquement
parlant on n'a pas de réponse à apporter
à ça et que humainement parlant et je
vais utiliser le terme de médicalement
parce que j'ai pas d'adjectif qui va
avec soignant mais en tout cas les
accompagner n'est pas un non sens en
tout cas dans les pratiques médicales ça
pose aussi la question de l'anticipation
et là je enfin je rejoins tout ce qu'on
dit mais mes collègues mais la question
de l'anticipation c'est toujours une
question de quelqu'un qui va bien
et la plupart du temps et qui se dit
purée moi j'aimerais pas être dans cet
état là j'aimerais pas qu'en fait mes
enfants soient obligés de me voir alors
que je suis dans cet état là donc ça ça
nécessite de se confronter à ça et alors
et d'avoir je suis pas sûr que les
directives anticipées soient un outil
très pratique mais par contre d'avoir
des discussions anticipées avec ses
proches avec son médecin traitant et
quand on sent qu'il y a potentiellement
un risque médical ou autre qui arrive de
pouvoir exprimer ça de pouvoir l'écrire
de pouvoir lacter et de pouvoir de fait
réfléchir parce que toutes les je parle
en scientifiques toutes les études qu'on
a aujourd'hui que ce soit l'état du
sujet les personnes veulent de la
quantité de vie
elles veulent vivre même quand elles ont
plein de trucs qu'elles veulent vivre
encore un tout petit peu plus longtemps
pour voir leur petit enfant pour voir
encore le jour une nouvelle fois
et pour finir avec les échanges avec nos
sociétés sans vente oui bien sûr on
échange avec la société belge donc où on
pratique l'euthanasie et la société
suisse en particulier qui font partie
des sociétés francophones de gériatrie
et gérontologie on a
quasiment à sec séminaire il y a une
réflexion sur les situations d'aide
médicale à mourir et tout ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que chacune d'entre
elles nous envies beaucoup la loi qui
laisse Leonetti parce qu'elle n'existe
pas dans ces pays-là et que aujourd'hui
une des choses qui mettent beaucoup en
avant je parle en gériatre je n'ai pas
le savoir universel mais et qui nous
inquiète nous personnellement c'est les
débordements qu'elles ont en particulier
la société
belge néerlandaise au niveau des
personnes atteintes de maladies
d'Alzheimer qui ont exprimé à un moment
ou un autre
de leur vie avant d'être atteint par la
maladie que il souhaitait pas se
projeter ainsi et qui souhaitait que si
ça leur arrive un jour et ben on les on
les je sais pas comment ça s'appelle
mais en tout cas on les voit on les
euthanasie on accélère leur départ et
qui a de plus en plus en fait de ces
actes là et que ces actes-là ne sont pas
toujours déclarés comme vous le savez
enfin si vous y êtes allé ils ont un
réseau national où on doit acter tout ce
qui est fait et qu'en tout cas il y a
beaucoup de médecins qui disent bah de
toute façon comme c'est autorisé et
qu'aujourd'hui il y a cette possibilité
là on le fait mais administrativement on
le déclare pas tout le temps et
là-dessus il y a une publication qui est
sortie récemment
en Hollande à ce à ce propos et voilà ça
nous pose ça nous interroge d'une façon
ou d'une autre mais ça c'est la posture
est-ce que pour le suicide on n'a pas
forcément besoin des soignants pour le
l'euthanasie on a besoin d'avoir les
soignants donc la posture de la société
par rapport au corps médical ce sont
c'est encore une zone une zone de
flottement mais je crois sincèrement
qu'il y a toute une posture de
communication vis-à-vis des
citoyens les soins palliatifs ne sont
pas encore assez développés on est tous
d'accord il y a certaines choses qu'on
réclamé depuis depuis la loi kless
Leonetti et qui n'ont plus vu revoir qui
n'ont plus voir le jour qui appartient
de la deuxième vague covid comme quoi
des fois les crises permettent de
déclencher aussi des choses mais
clairement aujourd'hui ben on est
toujours dans une insuffisance et qu'on
voudrait qu'avant tout cette
insuffisance soit comblée pour
accompagner pour proposer un
accompagnement et un soin de qualité
avant de proposer autre chose qui sera
peut-être nécessaire pour la société
mais en tout cas qui
l'alternative
poussait la vie jusqu'au bout parfois au
prix de l'acharnement thérapeutique
versus rien c'est pas acceptable pour
les professionnels que nous sommes
oui je fais rapporter à partager
quelques éléments supplémentaires
notamment sur
cette question de
au-delà du développement des soins
natifs
en termes de moyens je pense qu'il est
important aussi que dans notre pays
l'ensemble des professionnels de son
santé quel que soit leur spécialité quel
que soit leur mode d'exercice
hospitalier ou libéraux se saisissent de
cette question de la fin de vie et ça
c'est pas forcément une question encore
très facile et très aisée
l'importance du développement d'une
culture palliative à mon avis est
indispensable alors c'est sûr que dans
la vie d'un médecin généraliste je crois
que
chaque médecin généraliste accompagne
environ deux ou trois patients en fin de
vie par an dans son exercice de médecin
généraliste en moyenne
malgré tout je pense que ces questions
autour de à la fin de vie mais plus
largement autour de ce que je disais
effectivement sur l'obstination des
raisonnable sur la réflexion
amener et là encore c'est quelque chose
qui est quand même bien décrit et bien
expliqué dans la loi notamment ce qui a
expliqué un petit peu Sophie mougat tout
à l'heure sur le les questions de
délibération collégiale qui est aussi un
dispositif législatif qui
malheureusement aujourd'hui n'est pas
suffisamment connue et suffisamment
appliqué et qui fait que dans certaines
situations il est plus simple
effectivement
de maintenir deux continuer un
traitement qui n'a plus forcément de
sens un traitement dont le malade ne
veut plus forcément mais beaucoup de
patients en fait
n'ont pas
l'idée et ça j'en rencontre très
régulièrement qu'il est possible
et que la loi le dit qu'il est possible
de refuser de ne pas accepter la mise en
route d'un traitement ou de demander son
arrêt
quand je vous disais vous m'interrogiez
tout à l'heure sur le la question de
l'obstination des raisonnable est-ce que
c'est une réalité aujourd'hui oui je
pense que c'est une réalité importante
parce que beaucoup de professionnels de
santé ne prennent pas ce temps de la
délibération collégienne et je pense que
effectivement dans l'évolution naturelle
de la maladie de des patients qu'on
accompagne
il faut par moment se poser à plusieurs
ça nécessite pas forcément deux ou trois
heures de réflexion autour de la
situation d'un malade parfois un quart
d'heure parfois 20 minutes avec le
médecin avec l'infirmière avec
l'aide-soignante avec tous les gens qui
connaissent bien le malade avec le
médecin traitant quand il est disponible
ça peut se faire par téléphone ou en
visioconférence mais réfléchir à ce
qu'on va proposer aux malades et
effectivement on est quand même
aujourd'hui moi je suis marqué et
c'était encore le cas la semaine
dernière j'ai vu
patients qui patiente très âgée avec une
démence très avancée une altération très
importante de son état général dialyser
depuis une dizaine d'années et depuis un
an une réflexion qui n'arrive pas à
aboutir sur est-ce qu'il est pertinent
et ce qu'il est raisonnable de maintenir
cette dialyse chez cette personne dont
on sait que elle risque de mourir dans
les jours dans les semaines qui viennent
voilà je pense que
cette question là de la délibération
collégiale est très importante juste un
mot aussi concernant les relations qu'on
peut avoir avec les autres sociétés
savantes d'autres pays je vous invite à
aller voir sur le la chaîne Youtube de
la SFAP nous menons régulièrement des
conférences avec les sociétés françaises
étrangères la dernière concerne la
société française de soins palliatifs de
d'Autriche puisque l'Autriche a
légiférée sur le suic résister oui nous
avons des échanges nous avons des
échanges avec les Suisses avec les
Belges avec les Hollandais avec les
Canadiens tous ces pays où la loi a été
votée sur une forme d'aide active à
mourir et beaucoup d'entre eux nous
disent que contrairement à ce qui avait
été promis
les soins palliatifs n'ont pas vécu un
bon en avant
en termes de développement en termes
d'activité après le vote de la loi ils
sont plutôt freinés
dans leur développement et notamment
dans ce que je disais au début de mon
intervention dans le développement de
cette culture de cette culture paliative
voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire sur
sur les questions posées
beaucoup de choses ont été ont été dites
je voudrais juste revenir avec des
angles différents sur certains points
sur l'obstination des raisonnable et le
traitement déraisonnable oui c'est ça
existe mais
il faut s'imaginer le courage nécessaire
pour voir impatient les yeux dans les
yeux et lui dire on va arrêter de
traiter la maladie on va faire autre
chose et on va faire des soins
palliatifs
d'abord les soins palliatifs la plupart
du temps ça n'est pas compris c'est à
dire ce qu'on comprend c'est la fin de
vie et dans la fin de vie on comprend la
fin or c'est pas ça du tout c'est une
réorientation de la prise en charge
c'est à dire qu'au lieu de continuer à
vouloir se battre contre une maladie on
va s'occuper du confort du patient et
l'accompagner dans le temps qui est
susceptible de lui rester qui est non
mesurable qui peut être de quelques
jours de quelques semaines de quelques
mois voire de quelques années mon record
dans les tumeurs cérébrales alors que ça
paraissait complètement perdu c'est
quand même trois ans de soins palliatifs
donc ça veut pas dire la fin ça veut
dire une réorientation de la de la prise
en charge
et un problème de formation c'est-à-dire
que le courage pour pouvoir discuter de
soins palliatifs avec un patient avec la
pression familiale avec l'ensemble de
l'organisation ça n'est pas donné à tout
le monde de pouvoir discuter ce point et
c'est beaucoup plus facile de dire ben
on va faire une petite chimiothérapie
supplémentaire pour la route c'est
beaucoup plus facile on continue alors
qu'on sait que on ne va pas arriver
alors
c'est pas ma pratique
depuis le temps mais quand même ça
existe et puis il y a l'urgence
impatient une nuit s'aggrave brutalement
va se retrouver en réanimation parce
qu'on a voulu le prendre en charge alors
qu'il aurait pas fallu et après comment
est-ce qu'on va on va faire ça arrive et
c'est lié au fait qu'on n'a pas
suffisamment anticipé les choses
discuter préparer pour pas que ça se
produise
le droit de décider de sa fin de vie je
pense personnellement que c'est un
fantasme personne ne peut lire dans une
boule de cristal prévoir ce qui va lui
arriver et décider de la façon dont ça
peut se produire sauf naturellement en
se suicidant mais alors pourquoi avoir
attendu aussi longtemps en tant que
commencer dès le début je pense qu'il y
a des choses dans la vie qui sont
importantes et dire moi je vais décider
ça sera comme ça ben non il y a des
événements de la vie qui qui se
produisent
le problème des familles
c'est un vrai souci et très souvent
les familles pensent que c'est elle
qu'il faut prendre en charge et que le
patient s'est accessoire et que ces
décisions en fait elles sont collégiales
et dans un certain nombre de cas sur la
décision et les directives anticipées il
existe des patients très gentils qui ne
veulent pas déranger et qui sont
susceptibles de dire oui si c'est trop
dur pour les gens que j'aime et qui sont
autour autant que ça s'arrête alors que
ça n'est pas leur décision c'est celle
des autres
donc c'est un élément extrêmement
important et ça nécessite un
accompagnement la présence des
discussions et de pondérer les les
choses
la dépendance et la prolongation de la
vie je crois que tout le monde
100% a peur de la dépendance et n'a pas
envie d'être dépendant pourtant les
événements de la vie arrivent et on peut
voir j'ai rencontré l'autre fois dans le
train quelqu'un qui a ni Brad ni jambes
pourtant je pense que vous l'avez vu à
la télévision ou faire des choses il vit
il vit et il a même rencontré l'amour
donc on n'a pas forcément besoin d'être
indépendant pour avoir une vie et une
vie normale
c'est jamais drôle pour personne c'est
toujours difficile mais ce que
j'explique toujours à mes patients qui
sont en train d'avoir des difficultés de
marche et qui vont pas pouvoir se
déplacer et que je vais devoir prescrire
un fauteuil roulant
quelle est la réelle différence entre un
fauteuil roulant et une voiture dans un
certain nombre de cas on va prendre sa
voiture pour aller dans un endroit à un
autre parce qu'on trouve ça beaucoup
plus pratique beaucoup plus rapide et
quelqu'un qui a été difficultés à se
déplacer s'il veut aller faire des
courses dans un magasin il va prendre
son fauteuil roulant on va le déplacer
s'il est capable de faire quelque pas
dans le magasin et de faire au moins il
ira et il pourra avoir une vie normale
donc la dépendance en fait c'est
relative et tout le monde a peur de tout
mais on peut arriver à vivre quand même
avec un handicap et vivre très très
correctement et parfois mieux que
certaines personnes qui sont qui ne sont
pas handicapés
je pense qu'on a un réel problème dans
notre société de compréhension du mot
soin palliatif et ça il y a une
éducation nécessaire pour pouvoir
comprendre ce que c'est comment est-ce
qu'on accompagne et c'est un
accompagnement et c'est pas la fin et
c'est pas parce qu'on a décidé des soins
palliatifs que tout va va s'arrêter
les échanges avec les sociétés savantes
notamment de Belgique et de Suisse sont
assez paradoxales c'est-à-dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'il y a deux mondes ils
sont pas différentes de nos activités à
nous et ceux qui requiert le
suicide assisté ou l'euthanasie en fait
sont des
patients parallèles ce que je veux dire
c'est que un neuroncologue Suisse ou
belge travail exactement comme un
neuroncologue français et n'a pas dans
sa clientèle ou en tout cas avec tous
ceux que j'ai pu discuter un volume
beaucoup plus important de classes
exceptionnelles qui demandent la mort
ça arrive mais ça reste extrêmement peu
important et puis la dernière question
était que faire pour les cas
exceptionnels qu'est-ce qu'il faut
proposer
j'ai pas de celui-ci
ça reste ça reste exceptionnel je pense
simplement que nous sommes très en
dessous de ce que nous pourrions
proposer pour l'accompagnement un
élément tout simple qui est dans le
cadre du plan cancer qui est
l'accompagnement de l'annonce diagnostic
on est très très loin de ce qui est
proposé dans l'annonce diagnostic parce
que nous n'avons pas les moyens nous
n'avons pas le personnel pour pouvoir
accompagner l'annonce diagnostic donc à
partir du moment on n'est pas capable de
faire ça bien évidemment
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie on a
des années-lumière de ce qu'on devrait
faire
alors on va prendre Florence cassarade
Raymond de pensée mange ensuite les
rapporteurs Corinne Imbert les autres
rapporteurs vous souhaitez intervenir
non pour l'instant non et Christine
bonfantidos Florence
oui merci moi je pense la loi klace
Leonetti a permis moi qui suis pédiatre
par exemple l'accompagnement soins
palliatifs en salle de naissance en face
ça a amené des
des progrès pour les médecins et mais
par contre la parlementaire que je suis
a été interpellé en post mortem par un
patient atteint de maladie de Charcot et
qui me suppliait de faire quelque chose
une fois que je serai parlementaire
ma question est la suivante est-ce que
dans le dans le des citoyen là de
bioéthique est-ce que le patient expert
est-il
associé finalement à ces discussions
deuxièmement moi je suis sur un milieu
assez rural et j'ai l'impression que les
patients ne sont pas accompagnés
on a on a encore des gens qui meurent de
cancer du pancréas dans les bras de
l'infirmière
dans d'autres souffrances
le soin palliatif à domicile n'existe
pratiquement pas il y a quelques
associations il y a des structures qui
vont à domicile mais finalement moi qui
accompagne mon mari atteint d'un cancer
quand deux jours avant de mourir il a
dit
ça fait deux jours que je demande que je
demande qu'on m'aide à mourir et il
était psychiatre personne ne m'a
m'écoute mais je lui dis dans ton état
de toute façon ça va pas tarder ça ça
suffit à calmer ce son anxiété une
parole a suffi néanmoins
lorsque lorsque j'ai demandé à
l'Institut bergonnier dont il dépendait
finalement qui nous a absolument pas
accompagné sur la sur la fin de vie
quel serait le protocole pochon de
morphine etc moi j'ai une naissance
sérologue j'étais bien entourée sur le
plan médical mais personne ne le
balconnière répondu non mais ce que vous
feriez là c'est beaucoup trop dangereux
dangereux pour qui enfin c'est
c'est une c'est une question
complètement absurde d'une réponse
complètement absurde qui m'a été faite
donc l'accompagnement à domicile ça
serait quand même l'idéal pour bien des
personnes mais selon l'endroit où on se
trouve selon l'équipe qui nous qui suit
etc sur le terrain c'est vraiment
catastrophique il y a pas eu de progrès
je pense du tout depuis les années 90
sur ce plan là on accompagnait enfin je
veux dire moi mon père était généraliste
des des gens à domicile il en a
accompagné
je me souviens avoir suivi là sur ces
visites c'était à l'époque pour le
généraliste pas le pain quotidien mais
pour les infirmières c'est encore des
choses qui se qui se présentent très
régulièrement
donc est-ce qu'il faut protéger tout le
monde de tout ou est-ce qu'il faut
carrément affronter les choses poser les
vraies questions et sans référer aux
patients expert
un monde de penser manche beaucoup de
choses sont tombées depuis que je
voulais prendre vos propres discussions
mais je pense que quand même il faut une
fois pour toutes dire que tout le monde
est d'accord sur le préalable qu'il faut
une culture palliative qu'il faut les
soins palliatifs partout etc il faut que
ça qu'on cesse quand même de s'interdire
de penser et qu'à les peu de colle qui
comme vous dites qui sont exceptionnels
personne ne dit moi je suis allée en
Suisse personne avec le avec les
ministres que les cas sont rares
eux-mêmes disent que en une année pour
4000 personnes c'est 5 quand vous dites
les doigts de la main tout le monde est
bien d'accord mais on doit parce que eux
ils font des soins palliatifs donc on
doit quand même s'autoriser à penser les
cas qui demeure ne serait-ce aussi que
pense que la possibilité d'y recourir
entraînerait quand même une certaine
incertaine apaisement dans la population
parce que il faut bien dire que jusqu'à
présent on le sait c'est quand
exceptionnel était réglé soit par un
réseau médical de proximité qu'on avait
où ils sont réglés à l'étranger on dit
il y a peu de cas en France mais les
personnes qui veulent qui sont dans
cette problématique là bon j'ai vu
l'excellent film les mots de la fin ces
personnes là elles vont en Belgique
elles vont en Suisse donc est-ce qu'on
les compte il faut les compter aussi un
petit peu pour s'obliger
à penser la situation donc c'est très
marginal c'est sûr moi ce que je
regrette effectivement c'est qu'il ait
fallu aller en Suisse pour rencontrer
une équipe palliative qui
pensait que pour ces cas exceptionnels
effectivement en Suisse vous savez que
c'est pas un droit mais c'est une
que effectivement pour les corps rares
qui se posaient elles pouvaient
effectivement
les accompagner enfin faire un suicide
ainsi
assister parce que quand même en France
enfin je veux dire
c'est quand même dingue que les soins
qu'on trouve aucune personne travaillant
dans les soins palliatifs qui pensent
positivement que on puisse en faire
positivement qu'on puisse effectivement
atterrir à certains conclusions de la
convention citoyenne parce que je pense
que
faut pas faire un procès de la
population est mal informée etc si elle
était en soins palliatifs toutes les
demandes toutes les
non non mais si parce qu'on dit souvent
les les Français ne connaissent pas les
soins palliatifs etc bien ce que je veux
dire c'est que il y a des cas
irréductibles enfin est-ce qu'on pense
les cas il réductibles ou ou
on se on se dit sont trop marginales
pour
pour être pensé et c'est vrai que
moi j'avais demandé quand a commencé la
mission parlementaire si en France il
existait des personnes travaillant parce
que bon on est allé où travaillait la
responsable de la Société française des
soins palliatifs qui effectivement nous
ont dit si la loi passe on démissionne
tous alors en gros on était tous
tétanisés pour penser une loi possible
mais
il y a quand même un problème un
problème un peu français de vent debout
quand même des services palliatifs
souvent parce que c'est pas appliqué
parce que c'est pas connu etc et moi je
voudrais terminer sur profonde et
continue parce que dans les cas où on en
parlait hier dans les cas où cela se
fait donc c'est quand même quelque part
puisque c'est irréversible on est bien
d'accord c'est quand même quelque part
une assistance enfin un processus quand
même
de morts qui s'enclenche quoi le
problème c'est que enfin le problème
c'est que on décide pas du moment ça
peut être plusieurs heures ou plusieurs
jours etc et il est vrai que
la demande dans ces cas-là aussi c'est
quelque part
est-ce qu'on peut décider du moment
c'est à dire de faire
la même chose mais dans un temps bref où
la famille peut être là enfin bon voilà
donc bon j'ai été un peu un peu
brouillonne je m'en aperçois
non en lui disant mais
je termine vraiment sur le fait que on
est allé à Montpellier on est allé à
Narbonne on est allé en Suisse moi je
suis très déçu d'une dichotomie du fait
qu'en France vraiment cette position là
est totalement tranchée du côté des
services de soins palliatifs alors que
en Suisse ils ont pensé les choses et
même ils ont mis des soins palliatifs
avant de mettre du suicide assisté donc
c'était antinomique d'aller à cela
alors maintenant les rapporteurs Corinne
Imbert Christine bonfantidos d'accord
merci madame la Présidente bien merci
Madame merci Monsieur pour pour vos
interventions ma question va être très
courte elle fait référence à la
recommandation numéro 15 de la vie 139
du CCN vous qui êtes des professionnels
qui accompagnaient chaque jour des
patients qu'est-ce que pour vous un
pronostic vital engagé à moyen terme
Christine Bonfanti merci ça sera un tout
petit peu plus long d'abord merci pour
vos témoignages et pour la discussion
engagée qui est qui est très riche je
voudrais savoir ce que vous répondez à
ceux qui opposent le droit à mourir de
voir de vivre et puis vous avez tous
témoigné en disant que effectivement
dans vos
dans vos carrières vous n'avez rencontré
que très peu de de personnes qui vous
demandaient de mourir et Paul Ricard a
fait un travail considérable sur sur la
fin de vie il a dit qu'effectivement il
n'y avait que 0,3% de la population qui
demandait
l'ultime recours donc à mourir donc
effectivement si on fait une comparaison
au niveau de la population ça fait
effectivement peu et ma question c'est
de savoir est-ce que vous pensez que si
on dépénalise l'euthanasie vous aurez
beaucoup plus de demandes nous sommes
allés en Belgique il y a très peu de
temps et
un médecin nous disait que il avait reçu
42 personnes donc l'année dernière qui
qui sont venus de France et qui ont
demandé l'euthanasie et pour finir
au docteur Moulias
vous parliez donc de l'isolement des
personnes âgées qui pourraient peut-être
par solitude aller vers ces demandes-là
Marie de Henzel dans un une tribune dans
le monde disait l'autre jour que entre
l'acharnement thérapeutique et
l'euthanasie elle valorisait une
troisième voie qui était le respect du
souhait du patient en fin de vie de ne
plus s'alimenter est-ce que vous avez
rencontré des cas dans vos services
cette espèce d'anorexie finale voulue
par les personnes âgées Michel meunier
qui a une petite question aussi comme
d'autres l'accination profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès bien sûr ce
n'est pas que la loi
questionnity mais c'est quand même la
mesure qui ici on s'en souvient avait
fait beaucoup discuté et je voulais
savoir à cette époque là mesdames et
messieurs qu'il était votre attitude sur
cette mesure
moi je terminerai par une question on
assimile souvent lorsqu'on parle de
cette loi fin de vie euthanasie et
suicide assisté
c'est quand même pas tout à fait pareil
je voulais savoir justement la
distinction que vous faites entre les
deux et si un choix devait être fait
est-ce que vous pensez que que qu'un
suicide assisté préférable à une
euthanasie
vous n'êtes pas obligé de répondre vous
pouvez
commencer par répondre à cette question
donc la différence entre l'euthanasie et
le suicide assisté si vous voulez vous
voyez que je précise
alors effectivement ce sont deux choses
très différentes le suicide assisté et
une assistance à la personne qui réclame
une mort anticipée de pouvoir se
suicider donc de lui procurer les
produits qui lui permettront de se
suicider alors le modèle suisse est
organisé vous le savez sûrement autour
d'associations qui vont accueillir la
personne malade qui fait ce type de
demande et lui donner un produit soit
par la bouche soit par voie
intraveineuse mais c'est le malade
lui-même qui va s'administrer le produit
en buvant le produit ou bien ouvrir la
molette de de la perfusion qui va faire
passer le produit qu'il va lui donner la
mort sur un modèle plus qui défend plus
encore l'autonomie du malade tel que le
modèle américain le modèle de l'Orégon
qui a été développé il y a très
longtemps maintenant
le malade fait la demande va voir un
médecin qui fait une prescription le
malade ressort avec la prescription du
produit va le chercher dans une
pharmacie et revient chez lui avec le
produit et il en fait ce qu'il en veut
soit il le prend soit il le prend pas
voilà à peu près les deux modèles
l'euthanasie effectivement
est un modèle très différent qui
fait intervenir le soignant qu'il soit
médecin ou infirmière qui sont quand
même les deux qui sont les plus
concernés par le geste tanazique et là
effectivement c'est important de
préciser que ce sont des choses bien
différentes
puisque l'intervention des soignants
vient changer quand même
à mon sens la relation des soignants
avec la personne malade et avec son
entourage nous on considère
qu'effectivement administrer un produit
létal donner la mort ça ne peut pas être
un soin voilà il faut pas que que
administrer un produit létal puisse se
faire dans le cadre du soin voilà je
pense que si vous semble indispensable
qu'une loi
qu'elle apparaisse il faudra quand même
prendre en considération le travail des
soignants le travail des médecins des
infirmières des aides-soignantes de
toutes les équipes de soins et pour nous
c'est essentiel de considérer qu'il ne
faut pas mélanger les deux voilà pour le
pour votre dernière question après je
pense que vous posiez la question et si
on l'égalise est-ce que ça fera
augmenter le nombre de demandes
je pense que personne ne sera obligé
bien évidemment d'aller vers
l'euthanasie ou le suicide assisté par
contre tout le monde se posera la
question et tout le monde devra se la
poser
je peux pas répondre à toutes les
questions concernant le pronostic vital
engagé à moyen terme
c'est extrêmement difficile c'est
extrêmement difficile qu'est-ce que
c'est que le moyen terme et ça a été
difficile aussi de définir qu'est-ce qui
était le court terme alors la société
française de d'accompagnement de soi
palliatifs avaient donné des
orientations qui ont été reprises par la
chaise pour dire que le court terme
c'était quelques heures à quelques jours
le moyen terme qu'est-ce que c'est
quelques semaines quelques mois c'est
extrêmement difficile on sait que
dans mon expérience il est extrêmement
difficile de définir si le patient va
vivre encore trois mois encore six mois
encore un an
quand le malade rentre je dirais dans un
état de grande fragilité
on sait qu'à n'importe quel moment son
l'État peut se dégrader et la mort peut
survenir
la question du moyen terme est
effectivement une question difficile
je dirais peut-être par
une réponse qui peut être ne va pas vous
convenir je définirais le moyen terme
comme si on m'interrogeait pour tel
problématique telle patient est-ce que
vous pensez
est-ce que vous seriez surpris si cette
personne décédée dans les six mois ou
dans les 12 mois qui viennent si moi je
réponds non on peut considérer
qu'effectivement il s'agisse du moyen
terme
mais c'est compliqué mais comme je pense
que
des
dans notre pratique effectivement comme
vous le dites
les malades sont très fragiles les
malades peuvent changer les malades
changent les malades ont des envies
différentes des besoins différents
ce qui est vrai aujourd'hui ne sera plus
vrai forcément dans 15 jours ou dans
trois semaines pour un malade dans
l'état se dégrade et les demandes ne
sont pas les mêmes je rejoins le
professeur Beck quand il disait que
l'esprit humain varie énormément en
fonction de l'évolution de la maladie et
des symptômes
donc je vais reprendre les questions
sont les questions sont très très
différentes le patient expert est le
soin palliatif à domicile c'est certain
qu'il y a une hétérogénéité sur le
territoire extrêmement important pour ce
qui concerne Lyon la métropole et les
soins palliatifs à domicile c'est très
développé dès qu'on sort un peu c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et beaucoup plus
difficile bien que ça dépendent encore
des agglomérations et des endroits où on
se on se trouve il est évident que la
problématique du médecin traitant qui
doit être le pivot de la prise en charge
de ces patients est absolument majeur et
qu'on voit un changement culturel les
médecins traitants ne sont pas ceux
qu'on a connu il y a 40 ou 50 ans et non
pas la même activité la même prise en
charge et ça devient extrêmement
difficile et je pense que c'est un point
absolument majeur pour le développement
des soins palliatifs à domicile
l'intervention du patient expert
c'est encore relativement confidentiel
il faut qu'on arrive à développer
l'intervention des patients de façon
beaucoup plus importante
[Musique]
la définition du pronostic vital engagé
à moyen terme
c'est une définition l'axe on a la
possibilité de dire et je pense que
c'est très bien parce que ça permet
justement de discuter de mettre en place
les choses en fonction de la situation
propre du patient et
par contre il faut qu'il y ait une
maladie ou un processus en cours qui va
conduire au décès on ne parle pas d'un
handicap ou de quelque chose qui est
fixé et qui n'évolue pas il faut qu'il y
ait une évolution et que cette évolution
soit claire on peut pas se trouver dans
cette situation avec un cancer en
rémission il faut que le cancer soit
actif on ne peut effectivement pas fixer
la durée mais en tout cas le processus
qui va conduire au décès doit être en
route et dans la vitesse est
parfaitement mesurée
le fait que la loi ne soit pas claire
sur cette notion me semble extrêmement
efficient pour son application parce que
ça permet aux médecins pas seulement à
un médecin mais collégialement de
discuter de cette évolution et de la
situation pour proposer la sédation
profonde
sur la notion de droit
à mourir
personnellement donc je suis pas juriste
et je vois pas ce que vient faire le
droit là-dedans
ça va nous arriver à tout
et de dire à un moment donné c'est un
droit
ça va nous arriver et je suis pas sûr
que ça soit bien de légiférer sur cette
sur cette possibilité
je reconnais parfaitement les
demandes que peuvent avoir certains
patients et c'est parfaitement ancré
chez certains
dans quel cadre légal lesquelles sont
incapables de le faire parce que le
handicap est tel que ils ne peuvent pas
se suicider là aussi on rentre dans la
rareté de rareté et c'est excellent
excessivement exceptionnel est-ce qu'il
faut pour ça ouvrir dépend d'une loi qui
permet de faire des tas d'autres choses
qui n'ont strictement rien à voir avec
les exceptionnels qu'on veut régler j'en
suis pas sûr
sur l'anorexie finale ça je laisserai
pour la gérontologie je n'ai jamais
observé ça dans ma pratique quotidienne
et
les anciennes pratiques avant la loi et
les sédations profondes je pense qu'il
faut jeter un voile pudique sur les
pratiques de nos anciens et
les choses étaient faites en fonction de
la loi des circonstances et de ce qui se
passait pas forcément
bien et dans la moralité complète
et je pense qu'on fait beaucoup mieux
aujourd'hui dans la prise en charge de
la fin de vie qu'on ne le faisait il y a
40 ans
madame la Présidente merci et
je voudrais vous répondre madame la
sénatrice je
j'aimerais vraiment vous si vous voulez
que
qu'on donne pas l'impression d'une
opposition du du monde médical notamment
par rapport aux citoyens ou l'inverse ou
cueillez il y a une peur du monde
médical de de voir une loi qui puisse
apparaître sur ce sujet hautement
délicat
je reviens vraiment à ce que j'ai dit il
y a une insatisfaction de l'application
aujourd'hui de cette loi classique et je
pense que nos réticences viennent du
fait qu'on n'a pas l'impression de tout
faire pour en arriver pas pour ne pas en
arriver là et je reprends mon propos je
ça ne veut pas dire qu'une loi n'est pas
nécessaire pour pour peu de peu de nos
citoyens peut-être
mais si vous voulez cette forme de
réticence elle est surtout liée à cette
insatisfaction je pense qu'on a au
quotidien et mon confrère l'a dit au
regard de la ville de Lyon par rapport à
l'organisation d'une d'une de soins
palliatifs mais il l'a aussi très lundi
il y a une inégalité territoriale qui
est majeure il y a c'est un point
crucial à mon avis dans notre société et
dans notre pays aujourd'hui où vous avez
des endroits où les choses sont
finalement peut-être assez bien
organisés à tout point de vue mais
d'autres endroits où il n'y a absolument
rien et où on se réfère simplement à un
médecin traitant et je rejoins aussi ce
qu'a dit le professeur Enora et je n'ai
absolument rien contre bien sûr nos
nouvelles générations mais mais le monde
change les les médecins changent aussi
et ce qui ce que nous on a vécu je pense
ne se vivra pas dans le futur par
rapport à l'investissement que que les
gens peuvent avoir au regard notamment
de ces fins de vie et c'est une réalité
notamment la vie il faut prendre
conscience
après vous avez cité madame la sénatrice
un point qui est quand même crucial je
vous assure que sur plan médical il y a
une différence entre aider un patient à
mourir en l'endormant en assistant en
faisant en sorte que la famille soit
présente en discutant en passant du
temps et ce temps ça va être peut-être
quelques heures quelques jours je ne
sais mais c'est un temps que moi quand
je parle aux familles qui est
extrêmement importante parce que c'est
un temps d'un deuil qui qui est majeur
en fait c'est un temps où les gens
prennent conscience tout en ayant une
personne qui certes n'est plus là d'une
certaine façon mais où il y a quand même
un souffle de vie encore et ça c'est un
point je pense qui est qui est
fondamental et notre société doit
accepter ça doit accepter que que la
mort existe et que on a une façon de
mourir et que cette façon
malheureusement on n'en est pas
forcément détenteur de cette façon et
que nous on est là par contre pour aider
et la différence c'est par contre que
lorsque vous pratiquez une euthanasie
vous avez un stéthoscope sur un thorax
et tout d'un coup vous avez un cœur qui
s'arrête et c'est vraiment vraiment je
enfin moi peut-être que là je parle
d'une façon trop personnelle mais il y a
une différence qui à mon avis majeur et
elle doit être comprise par rapport à
nous médecins mais aussi par rapport à
toutes les équipes paramédicales comme
comme l'a dit mon confrère donc je sais
pas si c'est répondre parfaitement à vos
préoccupations mais je pense que c'est
un sujet qui me paraissait important et
et mon confrère a parlé aussi du droit à
mourir je pense que malheureusement on a
un devoir à mourir et ce devoir on fera
tous et c'est peut-être un point quand
même qui vraiment j'insiste beaucoup
madame la sénatrice parce que c'est vos
propos mon un peu bouleversé par rapport
à ce que vous dites au regard de la
Convention des citoyens et on a
l'impression finalement que nous société
savante on est peu dans un recul dans
une dans une dans un non positionnement
ou dans une non volonté et finalement
c'est vrai vous vous nous renvoyez à
nous-mêmes mais je pense que c'est
insatisfaction de ce que l'on fait
aujourd'hui nous conduit à dire qu'on
n'a pas envie de faire un pas non plus
si vous voulez on n'a pas votre courir
vers autre chose tant qu'on n'a pas
franchi un pas qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
n'est pas mon avis parfait
au regard de ce que vous disez madame la
sénatrice par rapport aux pronostics
vital engagés à moyen terme mais je
pense que
ces propos sont vraiment typiques d'une
sorte de et vous l'avez bien rappelé de
d'incertitude mais qui nous sert bien
parce que finalement pronostic vital
engagé à un moyen terme ça veut pas dire
grand chose c'est surtout la façon dont
on y va est-ce qu'on y va bien est-ce
qu'on y va pas bien ce qu'on y va en
étant en paix avec soi-même ou pas avec
nos proches ou pas c'est effectivement
une définition qui est qui n'est pas
facile mais c'est incertitude dans la
définition je pense nous sert bien après
il a été rappelé le rôle des familles le
rôle des familles dans notre pratique je
vous assure c'est extrêmement difficile
vous avez des patients qui vont vous
dire moi j'ai une énorme souffrance je
veux mourir mais il peut changer d'avis
le lendemain et vous avez ensuite une
famille qui autour va vous dire mais
vous vous rendez compte c'est affreux ce
que vous avez dit à votre patient vous
lui avez dire qu'il allait mourir mais
à l'inverse on l'aurait pas dit on va
mais pourquoi vous dites rien en fait si
vous voulez on est dans des on est dans
des situations qui vraiment touche à
l'humain et je voudrais vraiment mettre
toutes toute la raison pour laquelle
j'ai fait ce métier c'est-à-dire en fait
toutes ces relations humaines qu'on crée
tous les jours et je pense que ça c'est
pas toujours facile de légiférer
là-dessus et je reprends ce qui a été
dit initialement par ma console la
formation est majeure et quand je dis la
formation c'est la formation par rapport
aux équipes paramédicales au médecin la
Formation en Soins palliatif n'est pas
assez reconnue et et faite dans nos
études de médecine la vie fait partie de
la mort et la mort fait partie de la vie
il est absolument nécessaire que nous
médecins nous ayons une formation qui
soit adéquate pour justement pouvoir
avoir une certaine paix intérieure le
jour où on va être finalement face à ces
situations là et la formation elle est
aussi vis-à-vis de nos citoyens je je
vendredi c'est c'est
je crois qu'il faut pas qu'on trompe nos
citoyens à aller jusqu'à entre
guillemets ces extrémités encore une
fois je ne condamne pas peut-être qu'une
loi est totalement nécessaire mais je
voudrais bien que nous citoyens et quand
même conscience que il y a aussi
d'autres possibilités et que c'est
possible lorsqu'elles sont bien faites
on arrive à entourer correctement les
gens bien sûr madame la sénatrice vous
avez eu une expérience qui est sans
doute un peu difficile et on en a tous
et on en aura encore parce que rien
n'est linéaire dans ces situations là je
reste convaincu que la notion de passion
expert est fondamentale il faut qu'on
s'appuie je crois vraiment à la à la
participation dans l'organisation des
soins à nos citoyens qu'ils soient
malades d'ailleurs ou qui ne le soit pas
après la question de savoir comment on
fait certes un peu plus compliqué mais
je reste convaincu que finalement celui
qui sait le plus c'est quand même
l'usagé et qui peut extrêmement nous
aider je pense que ça nous simplifierait
d'ailleurs beaucoup de choses dans nos
rapports avec notamment administration
par rapport à nos administrations par
rapport aux moyens qui sont parfois
donnés et puis l'organisation des soins
par rapport à ce que vous vous avez vécu
c'est sûr que c'est sans doute une
expérience une expérience qui est bon
après connaissant un peu l'Institut
Bergonié je pense qu'ils ont aussi une
organisation de de prise en charge qui
est quand même aussi compétente et c'est
vrai que parfois ça n'exclut pas qu'on
est et que qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
parfois pas très très bien faire
voilà je crois que j'ai j'ai
fait un peu le tour de toute vos
questions qui quand même en tout cas
pour certaines m'ont beaucoup interpellé
comme vous avez pu le voir merci
merci alors je vais essayer juste de
compléter je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit je ne pense
pas que les professionnels de toute
façon c'est pas notre métier d'écrire
des lois donc on peut pas s'opposer à
des lois il y en a qu'on a subi comme
tant d'autres et qu'on a mis en
application quand on nous a donné les
moyens de les mettre en application ça
c'est une autre chose parce que savoir
pour qui on écrit la loi en tout cas il
faut l'écrire avec ceux qui sont censés
la porter et c'est pour ça qu'on vous
remercie tous d'être là c'est qu'on est
déjà content qu'on nous parle dans
l'idée d'en faire une mais je m'inscris
en accord avec avec tous mes collègues
c'est que on est inquiet comme on vous
le transmet là de alors des applications
des dérives possibles et de la posture
et pour être
aussi clair que mon collègue qui pousse
la seringue en pratique voilà de qui
prend les médicaments ou qui les prend
pas parce que la véritable question
partout elle est là
ça c'est la première pour la posture
soignante la deuxième c'est que
voilà et c'est là où est la question
entre le suicide assisté et l'euthanasie
enfin le c'est de la question de qui qui
prend qui pousse voilà qui fait quoi en
pratique sur la question en fait qui
nous inquiète le plus c'est que comme la
très bien dit Madame les soins
palliatifs alors c'est un mot qui est
pas adapté mais la langue française
c'est pas non plus notre métier de la
réécrire mais aujourd'hui il y a les
soins de confort les soins de palliatifs
les soins de support c'est plein de
trucs qui sont un peu dans le même dans
le même registre dans la même frontière
et il y a aussi plein d'études qui
disent que par exemple quand on est à
atteint quand on diagnostique un concert
si on met en place des soins palliatifs
très rapidement ce qui n'empêche pas de
mettre en place une chimiothérapie
active ou une opération etc mais en fait
les patients le se ressentent mieux et
parfois vivent plus longtemps la
question du mieux n'intervient pas
forcément la question en fait c'est sur
des critères scientifiques et objectifs
mais en tout cas ils se sentent souvent
mieux que quand on a fait quand on n'a
pas mis ce soin de support palliatifs
comme on veut on l'appelle comme on veut
mais en tout cas il y a une question de
temps en fait de temporalité et ça c'est
ce que moi j'appelle l'accompagnement et
notre vrai inquiétude enfin notre
travail à tous là on accompagne tous des
maladies chroniques mortelles un moment
ou un autre que ça soit court moyen ou
long terme et que cet accompagnement là
qui fait le sens de nos professions si
en fait aujourd'hui il ne peut pas être
réalisé correctement comme la très bien
expliqué madame être dans le soin
palliatif ou d'être dans le soin
terminal ou être dans le soin de confort
ça se limite pas à donner de la morphine
des bases audiazépines une petite
transfusion pour que le cœur aille mieux
le temps du moyen terme à passer enfin
c'est pas tout ça ça c'est indispensable
pour que le corps du patient se sente
bien mais il y a le temps de l'humanité
et le temps de l'humanité c'est à dire
le temps d'être là à côté le temps de
pouvoir répondre à des questions
existentielles alors je parle pas
forcément de spiritualité même s'il a
spiritualité fait partie du
questionnement mais le
temps de l'accompagnement le temps
d'être là à l'autre de pouvoir répondre
à des inquiétudes de pouvoir donner un
sens de pouvoir donner de l'explication
aussi sur ce qu'on fait sur le reste du
temps à vivre sur comment ça se passe
comment est-ce que l'autre risque de
mourir pour de vrai est-ce que dans la
maladie que vous avez vous risquez
d'avoir une hémorragie cataclysmique et
donc il faut prévenir les dents est-ce
que la personne risque de s'endormir
tranquillement dans son lit et à ce
moment-là est-ce que les dents va rester
toutes les 5 secondes à essayer de
secouer pour vérifier que l'autre vit
encore tout ce temps là
c'est un temps qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas fait comme on souhaiterait
qu'il puisse être fait clairement
partout sur tout le territoire moi je
travaille dans le 92 qui est plutôt
réputé comme un département confortable
on a plus assez de médecins traitant on
a dû fermer une des équipes de soins
mobiles de soins palliatifs faute on va
dire de combattants quelqu'un a parlé de
combat ou de guerre tout à l'heure mais
voilà c'est faute de de bras d'âme de
gens qui sont là aujourd'hui encore la
prise en la comment dire le temps
psychologique enfin pouvoir offrir un
temps de psychologue si c'est pas en
équipe mobile c'est pas pris en charge
donc clairement il faut payer 40 balles
de sa poche à chaque fois qu'une
psychologue vient si elle vient à
domicile c'est encore plus cher il
pourrait y avoir un accompagnement pensé
autrement quand je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait des métiers à
créer je pense qu'il y a aussi et
aujourd'hui tout ça ce n'est porté que
par le bénévolat
et le bénévolat ben voilà c'est le
bénévolat et aujourd'hui en fait ce
qu'on demande aux soignants et ce qui
augmente l'inquiétude des soignants
c'est qu'on a passé tous les autres pays
qui ont écrit leurs lois d'aide médicale
à mourir ils l'ont écrit il y a
longtemps un certain temps où ils ont
adapté leur loi pour dépénaliser des
trucs qui ou autorisés comme en Espagne
des choses qui sont pas vraiment écrites
dans la loi en pure et dure mais ils ont
fait tout ça avant le covid nous on
réfléchit après le covid ou les
soignants ils ont pour le coup il y
avait que là pour vivre pour accompagner
pour être à côté et parfois pour
injecter ne pas injecter ne pas avoir
les médicaments ne pas avoir le droit
aux médicaments comme ça a été le temps
pendant longtemps en EHPAD parce que
c'était pas possible de les avoir et que
aujourd'hui en fait ils ont l'impression
qu'on leur demande de faire la diagonale
du fou et de prendre de leur dire ok ben
qu'il y a aussi aujourd'hui par rapport
aux personnes qui sont décédées est-ce
que est-ce que par exemple si j'ai le
droit à l'euthanasie on va pouvoir
meuthanasier chez moi alors que si je
dois rester mourir
normalement ça prendra peut-être plus de
temps et dans ce cas-là ça sera possible
confortablement qu'à l'hôpital parce que
il y a pas d'achat des là où j'habite ou
parce que l'achat des est pas suffisante
etc et ça c'est des vrais questions
pragmatiques où on sait qu'aujourd'hui
ben voilà l'alternative si vous voulez
elle est pas équitable en fait d'un côté
on est dans une société d'immédiatetée
et il y a un truc qui va vite et bien
avec certitude potentiel
j'anticipe sur des choses et de l'autre
côté il y a quelque chose plein
d'incertitudes qui est potentiellement
en tout cas où on sait qu'aujourd'hui on
n'est pas encore dans 100% des cas
confortables et avec un accompagnement
parfait on a quand même une majorité de
médecins traitants aujourd'hui qui
refusent
[Musique]
quand on est dans le point négatif il
est dans le confort il est dans le temps
de la mort dans le dans des choses très
techniques et pas forcément dans le
temps empathique pour ce qui est du
pronostic vital engagé alors quand on
est on va dire après 80 ans le pronostic
vital est engagé à
voilà tout le temps un moment ou un
autre parce que la vie est une maladie à
pronostic vital engagé à long terme on
espère pour l'immense majorité de nous
je suis d'accord avec mon collègue sur
l'intérêt de garder ce flou parce que ce
flou là il permet aussi de discuter avec
le patient de discuter avec la famille
que le patient puisse aussi
s'organiser et se mettre en posture de
alors à condition d'avoir la discussion
avec lui c'est pour ça d'où l'intérêt
aussi de ce que j'ai appelé les
discussions anticipées c'est ça permet
de dire ben là votre maladie
les
potentiellement si je vais le dire de
façon un peu courte parce qu'on n'a pas
le temps de faire une consultation
d'annonce mais voilà que là peut-être
s'il y a des choses à faire si vous
voulez organiser des choses dans vos
affaires si vous voulez voir c'est
peut-être le moment d'appeler vos
enfants c'est peut-être le moment et on
passe dans une autre dynamique en fait
ce qui veut pas dire que nous on est
plus là mais qu'on passe dans une
dynamique différente dans le cas où lui
il peut aussi prendre cette posture de
dire bah là si ça si ça s'aggrave un peu
plus et ben je veux plus aller plus loin
et où on peut à ce moment là
partir sur la sédation profonde et
continue on sait qu'il faudra parce que
la sédation profonde et peut continuer
c'est pas un truc qu'on sort comme ça en
disant alors parfois oui mais en tout
cas dans nos pratiques à nous c'est
souvent quelque chose qu'on anticipe ou
après une discussion avec les patients
ils nous disent ben voilà là moi je je
veux plus je veux plus ça je veux être
endormie je voudrais ne pas voir ne pas
et il y en a qui nous disent je veux pas
et d'ailleurs souvent quand on dit là
vous souffrez trop on va commencer la
morphine en continu etc il me dit non
non moi je veux pas mourir je veux pas
de morphine alors on est obligé de
discuter raconter que expliquer que
c'est pas la morphine qui tue c'est la
vie enfin c'est là où c'est la fin mais
que la morphine est là pour soulager et
que de toute façon dormir c'est avec une
autre drogue que la morphine qu'on est
là dans d'autres choses
est-ce que si on augmente enfin si on si
la loi arrive est-ce que la demande va
va augmenter ben je pense qu'il y a
toujours un effet d'annonce d'ailleurs
dans les sociétés en particulier dans la
société belge ils nous ont bien expliqué
que quand ils avaient il y a de
nombreuses années quand ils avaient mis
le processus en place ils ont eu plein
de demandes et puis qu'après les choses
se sont se sont stabilisés voilà il
reste la question et sur laquelle je
suis tout à fait d'accord de la
culpabilisation c'est que si une fois de
plus on développe pas l'accompagnement
en tout cas la possibilité d'être là à
l'autre à côté il restera qu'on sait que
quand on est très âgé ou quand on
commence à devenir très handicapé et que
c'est compliqué de plus en plus d'avoir
des aides d'avoir le droit à certaines
choses il y a il y a un âge où le droit
n'est plus le même pour tout le monde
pour le pour l'économie pour plein de
choses et donc peut-être pour la santé
aussi et ben
on sent bien qu'elles sont là on devient
un poids pour la société et que
cette réflexion elle elle est chez les
plus âgées elle est aussi chez les
patients avec des maladies de Charcot
qui commence à s'interroger sur leurs
droits à vivre et que il faudrait pas
que ça soit de ce fait là en fait et
mais l'humain est assez ambivalent en
tout cas dans le pour ce qui est de la
de la Suisse et de la enfin moi en
Suisse j'ai travaillé en Suisse pendant
un très peu de temps mais voilà pendant
six mois à Genève et et il y avait des
enfin il y a encore des il y a des
patients qui qui disent ben c'est un
abonnement en fait en Suisse c'est un
abonnement qui coûte cher et donc qui
disent bah là j'ai déjà coûté cher en
fait tout ce que j'ai dépensé pour pour
avoir le droit à dire dont je ne me suis
passée en fait c'est tout cet argent là
que je ne donnerai pas à mes enfants
donc il faudrait mieux que je meure mais
j'y arrive pas voilà je n'arrive pas à
franchir ce pas là alors c'est là aussi
c'est une situation parmi plein d'autres
mais il y a beaucoup il y a quand on
voit les statistiques de l'Oregon ils
ont aussi plein de patients à qui plein
de personnes à qui qui ne l'ont jamais
pris ce qui pose la question de ce qu'on
fait des médicaments après oui c'est pas
contradictoire mais c'est voilà ça fait
partie de la vie aussi et des choses
compliquées et puis je finirai avec
parce que il y a plein de choses qui ont
déjà été dites avec la question de ne
plus s'alimenter
[Musique]
refus de soins parce que l'alimentation
est un soin aujourd'hui en tout cas dans
les milieux où il y a du soin
ça pose la question en fait
immédiatement généralement les familles
demandent à ce qu'on pose des sons de
nasogastiques etc
aujourd'hui là aussi je vais parler en
scientifiques quand quelqu'un a décidé
qu'il allait mourir
dans sa tête quelque part même si on
communique pas avec lui et ben quand il
est à cette époque là de sa vie il va
mourir quoi qu'on fasse et si on lui met
si on fait une
déjà faut avoir accès à normalement à la
à la parole de l'autre elle son
autonomie d'une façon ou d'une autre
pour lui imposer des soins techniques
tels que la sonde naso gastrique mais
voilà sans raison médicale qui fait que
l'alimentation ne soit pas possible
comme dans un AVC par exemple où il y a
une temporalité de vie possible derrière
mettre de la technicité ne sert à rien
en fait ne fait que potentiellement
compliquer le temps du mourir parce que
et ben la sonde c'est désagréable c'est
pas forcément ça peut faire mal ça peut
faire plein de choses etc mais qu'en
tout cas on n'est pas aujourd'hui ça
fait partie des choses
connu et reconnu des professionnels mais
pas forcément
à juste titre de la population générale
parce que ça n'a pas obligé d'être connu
de tous mais ça fait partie des choses
qu'il faut savoir reconnaître et
accepter mais pas forcément du premier
coup c'est à dire qu'il faut se donner
un temps un temps d'intérêt à l'autre un
temps d'approche à l'autre et que ce
temps là quand on est en EHPAD et ben il
faut qu'il y ait un médecin traitant qui
veille bien voir le patient un médecin
coordonnateur il y a au moins 30% des
EHPAD qui n'ont pas de médecin
coordinateur sur le territoire français
et donc pas quelqu'un qui dégaine tout
de suite en disant ok bah vu son âge
c'est que c'est fini on laisse on laisse
tomber et on passe à autre chose et ça
c'est une vraie ça fait partie des aussi
des problématiques
d'accompagnement que je vous ai précisé
avant
merci merci beaucoup pour cette audition
bien merci beaucoup et
peut-être un prochain texte
on vous entendre il a annoncé quelque
chose à la rentrée on verra bien